hallo minecraft ist laut mir bis gut
und damit alle meine lieben freunde zu
einer weiteren mine kraft net
vorstellung ich hab's euch ja indem
minecraft gta 5 map review von n11 tk
schon gesagt dass ich euch das ganze mal
mitgliedschaft line zeigen werde
und zwar seht ihr hier schon hier ist
was ist denn los mit man minecraft wieso
sind sie so komische rendering boxsack
emi darum geht wie hier drin wenig dran
dumme den wir sind da immer noch solche
praxis geworden sind liegt auf jeden
fall nicht was los ist denn was ist wird
meine minecraft los was soll da wenn ich
die sichtweite auf 12 chance habe dann
geht's wieder
ich weiß nicht woran das liegt
eigentlich schafft mein pc locker 25
chance noch und noch wenn ich in shape
drin hätte und was weiß ich irgendwann
das ganze ein bisschen rendering bugs
und zwar weil ich euch nur in einem ganz
kurzen info video sagen diese clash of
kleins maps also ich hab ja damals mal
minecraft lenzen video gemacht was ist
alles schon bezüglich minecraft und
chaplins gibt weil bei mir auf minecraft
gewünscht wird aber auch sehr oft
deswegen habe ich gesagt erich verbindet
euch das ganze zeit das brennt hat nicht
ernsthaft ab tatsache ohne witz es
bringt einfach ab das ist jetzt bisschen
traurig wir brennen einfach gerade alles
ab egal was los also ich habe auf jeden
fall damals gesagt dass kleins und
minecraft habe ich das richtige vor ich
heute gehen wir manchmal echte gefühle
durch also ich hab euch damals hab da
was für euch und zwar habe ich euch da
einfach ja ein paar download-links
gegeben zu ein paar clash of plants maps
und halt eine server ip zu einem server
wo man sich ganz ganz ganz viele clash
of dance gebäude anschauen könnte
anschauen kann und das ist dieser server
und daher jetzt max taut auf kleins
minecraft bates gemacht also
beispielsweise mit diesem grau schwarzen
kassen
bauern dann mit den größten elixir lager
mit den größten laboren mit den mit den
größten mit der größten days
beispielsweise die einfach tot ist ja
ich weiß nicht was ich davon halten soll
das ist einfach dafür alles abfackeln
aber ich wollte auf jeden fall nur sagen
es gibt jetzt einen download link von
dieser map also es gibt nicht mehr nur
noch dieses jahr die bao bao bao hütten
oder videos ich spiele halt echt nur
noch selten clash of planes weil mich
das spielen nicht mehr so sehr reizt ich
bin lieber monster legions oder so aber
ich finds auf jeden fall mega cool dass
die jetzt den downloadlink rausgehauen
haben und es sieht auf jeden fall
richtig nass aus also ich finde es sieht
richtig cool aus und das soll jetzt
basel sind updates seien ihr findet in
der beschreibung download links zu
dieser map ihr findet sondern aus dem
penis aber ich dort ist die kanone
ich finde den link in der beschreibung
wo ihr auch einfach auf die server gehen
können weil die noch ein gta web machen
den link dazu findet ihr auch in dem
schreiben das ist nicht mehr schön dass
hier einfach grades am verrecken ist ein
bisschen leid für diese ganze mary
einfach mit so viel liebe gebaut ist
einfach die krassesten sachen und so wir
findet einen link dazu und so weiter
unten in der beschreibung wenn ihr euch
das ganze darf man schon wird wo ich
gerade hin fliege weiß gerade selber
nicht wie sie fliege ich denn es
überhaupt gerade heraus ich vor die
theorie also es ist auf jeden fall mal
einen blick wert wenn es bei euch dann
nicht auch direkt auch abstürzt hier so
etwa also dass wir alles gerade einfach
mal anfängt zu brennen
finde ich auf jeden fall richtig cool
ich finde auch man könnte dem nlv pager
einfach mal lassen oder so weil ich
finde einfach dass in die besten
minecraft ich wollte euch jetzt mal so
noch mal ganz kurz
diese kleines mädchen zeigen der
download links draußen ich finds mega
komisch dass das ganze jetzt einfach
hier alles abgefackelt ist hab ich auch
noch eine frage an euch und zwar das was
ich wünschen hatte ich wenn ich einmal
die die dings ihr verändere ich hab das
ja immer plus normal auf 12 weil ich
lust auf diesen nebel habe aber wenn ich
jetzt mal auf +21 packen es läuft immer
noch flüssig also ich kann hier alles so
ganz flüssig mich hier mich im moment
gehen aber wenn ich dann in entfernung
schoss in der teilweise richtige
rendering fehler wenn ihr euch das hier
mal anschaut da ist wie im sommer
horrorfilm oder so und hier geht dann
wieder so alles hier ist wieder alles
super auch mit regen und so von frames
keine ahnung in frames habe ich hallo
kann
ich weiß gar nicht wieviele frames aber
nicht behindert werden denn die adag um
150 frames trotz dessen okay die fremd
schützenden wald im hintergrund gerade
wieder in welche rendering beachten doch
auf 30 frames eingestellt ich vollidiot
jedenfalls es läuft alles flüssig bei
mir ist auf gut aber das ist trotzdem
solche komischen rendering fehler also
ich weiss es regnet gerade und so und
das ruckeln alles ein bisschen aber ich
weiß nicht was diese rendering fehler
sollte also wenn ihr da irgendwer wenn
er in der ahnung hat was ist wenn ich da
rein fliege es ist also wenn da
irgendwer gegen die idee hat bevor ich
in epileptischen anfall krieg oder so er
ist auf jeden fall richtig cool wenn wir
das in die kommentare schreiben könnte
wenn ihr noch weitere maps habt von den
spielen weil sie nicht irgendwelche
coolen spiele oder eben was cooles was
der minecraft innovatives nachgebaut
wurde was die klasse findet was sich
vorstellen könnte damit die macher da
ein bisschen mehr aufmerksamkeit für
bekommen sage ich mal
dann schreibt mir einfach in die
kommentare dann würde ich sagen meine
lieben freunde wenn es euch trotzdem
gefallen hat ich weiß es weil es so
quasi so ein update video von dem
letzten crash of plants video aber im
letzten gletscher kleines video halte
ich eine scheiß frisur und war nur auf
dem server und jetzt gibt es ein
download-link also dessen beschreibung
ladet euch die app einfach mal runter
und dann würde ich mir wenn bewertung
von wir sehen uns doch ein bisschen
beängstigend aus